ich habe in einem Restaurant aus der
Zukunft gegessen und das kann ich
wirklich sagen weil dieses Restaurant
ist unvergleichlich einfach weil es
keinen Vergleich gibt zu dem was wir da
gesehen und erlebt haben und das
Restaurant von dem ich rede heißt eat
Rennen glaube ich habe selten so
häufigsten Restaurant von euch
zugeschickt bekommen und spätestens als
ich da war wusste warum aber erstmal
habe ich mir die Website angeschaut so
geht das ganze los new dimensions auf
dining neue Dimension des Essens Sinn
des Reise starten klicken wir einfach
mal Boom dann geht's los bitte scrollen
es ist wirklich cool taste to believe
sogar hier sieht man schon dass das eine
multi-sensorische Reise sein wird also
alle Sinne werden irgendwie mitgenommen
und es gibt einem nicht wirklich ein
gutes Gefühl für das was passiert ist
eine schöne Website auf jeden Fall aber
ich war auf jeden Fall geflasht als wir
da waren okay wo stehen wir jetzt das
Restaurant Konzept will uns auf eine
Sinnesreise mitnehmen verschiedene Dinge
erleben eigentlich eine Sache die mehr
oder weniger auch schon in anderen
Restaurants stattgefunden hat wir waren
im ochsenklebus um x Taste ging also
quasi total breit aufgefächert Geschmack
zu erleben deshalb habe ich mir schon
gedacht das kann nicht alles sein und
als wir vor Ort waren und dann vor dem
Laden standen wusste ich schon das ist
etwas ganz Besonderes ich habe mich
gerade schon nach der ganzen Erfahrung
sprechen und jetzt geht's los ich bin so
aufgeregt ich erwarte unheimlich viel
los geht's ab ins Restaurant der Zukunft
riesige Deckenhöhen wunderschönes Design
klare Linien absolut modern es lag so
etwas in der Luft und das hat sich
wirklich angefühlt als wäre man
irgendwie in der Zukunft keine Ahnung
vielleicht lag es auch an der Frau die
die Drinks ausgeschenkt hat die aussah
wie von Tribute von Panem mit diesem
Bubble Kleid was sie an hatte oder ich
weiß es nicht die Musik die lief
Projektionen an den Wänden es war
einfach es hat so eine Grundnote gesetzt
für das was folgen sollte so dann haben
wir drei gereicht bekommen also drei
kleine Gaumen Freuden die man quasi vor
dem eigentlichen Menü bekommt sah alles
super hübsch aus aber auch nichts was
man nicht kennt also dass man irgendwie
so ein Kleinigkeit gereicht bekommt in
einem schönen Restaurant aber eine Sache
war Präsident und zwar dieser Timer an
der Wand der langsam aber sicher
runtergetickt hat bis wir dann letzten
Endes aufgerufen wurden uns wurde gesagt
dass leider nicht in allen Räumen
gefilmt werden darf was eigentlich voll
verständlich ist weil das ist ja ein
einmaliges Erlebnis das Erlebnis
verkaufen sie und wenn wir das in vollen
Umfang zeigen würden wäre es ja ein
bisschen langweilig deshalb leider nicht
alles aber ich habe ja hier oben noch
ein bisschen was drin so weiß ich dass
wir dann um ein digitalen Brunnen oder
Wasserfall standen alles ein bisschen
erklärt bekommen haben dennoch ein
Aperitif gereicht bekommen haben und
dann den ersten Raum betreten haben
dieser war komplett weiß wir hatten eine
Projektion wo wir uns hinstellen sollten
alles war schon hochtechnisiert und dann
standen wir davor ja irgendwas
abgedeckte mit einer weißen plane der
Raum komplett weiß wirklich wie im
Science Fiction Film und dann ging so
eine Show los man hat plötzlich eine
Stimme gehört willkommen in der Zukunft
Genussreise ich kriegs nicht mehr eins
zu eins zusammen aber plötzlich fliegt
diese plane hoch und runter stehen
unsere Stühle und ihr denkt jetzt hä was
ist daran besonders es ist sehr
besonders weil diese Stühle und das ist
das Herzstück von fahren von selbst
durch die Reise man fährt von Raum zu
Raum von Erlebnis zu Erlebnis von Show
zu Show und es fühlt sich wirklich
absurd an und es ist am Anfang gar nicht
so dass das Grinsen aus dem Gesicht
gegangen weil es war so es hat sich
nicht echt angefühlt was ich wirklich so
futuristisch angefühlt hat und vom
ersten Moment an war der Name eatanalyn
Programm naja dann haben wir uns auf
unsere Fahrschule gesessen und sind in
den ersten Raum Gefahren den Ocean Raum
in dem wir zum Glück Filmen durften
[Musik]
Restaurant aus der Zukunft ist der
Begriff die Bezeichnung für das was ihr
abgeht jetzt schon so ein Flash wir
hatten gerade noch eine Kleinigkeit
vorab auch unfassbar gut geschmeckt hat
dass wir hier erleben können seht ihr
jetzt hier dürfen nur zwei Räume in den
gegessen wird dürfen wir heute mitnehmen
leider aber ich freue mich umso mehr die
anderen auch ohne Kamera erleben zu
dürfen oder was ist das verstehst du
irgendwas nein man muss dazu sagen die
Technik ist auch so beeindruckend diese
Stühle hier gibt's keine Schienen oder
irgendwas erleben wir hier gerade wir
drehen uns auch jetzt gerade so um diese
Bar die dort in der Mitte steht also
alle Tische rotieren gerade ganz ganz
leicht aber auch so in verbunden die
vier Tische sind zu einem geworden ja
das fühlt sich so an als würden wir
jetzt unseren Freundinnen ganz entspannt
sitzen normalen Tisch ja einfach
unfährten riesiges animiert das Aquarium
haben wir ein paar felswende können
leckeren Weißwein eingeschenkt bekommen
hier eingedeckt wurde
Zange ein Löffel das ist wirklich
überwältigend also man kann es wirklich
nur überwältigen wenn man checkt das gar
nicht gerade wir geben uns natürlich
große Mühe das bestmöglich für euch auch
einzufangen weil
mit Licht mit Ton und allem drum und
dran so es ist nicht ganz einfach das
hier irgendwie aufzunehmen aber wir
wollen es so gut wie möglich für euch
wiedergeben eine Sache ist aber glasklar
man muss sich darauf einlassen können
wenn man jetzt irgendwie 70 Jahre alter
Banker ist der Zick Michelau Restaurants
durchlaufen hat und Perfektion erwartet
kein Schnickschnack dann bist du da
falsch also du musst Bock auf diese Show
haben weil es geht einfach mehr als
Essen es geht vor allem würde ich fast
sagen um das Erlebnis also waren wir
angekommen im ersten Raum es hat
wirklich geflasht ich hoffe ihr kriegt
das ein bisschen mit von der Kamera weil
natürlich das ist ja wie gesagt so für
alle Sinne und wenn ihr nur guckt und
hört in dem Video nimmt das natürlich
nicht so sehr mit wie wir es da gefühlt
haben aber auch die erste Speise die wir
hatten die einfach versteckt war in
unserem Stuhl
Meeresfrüchte ich verstehe gar nichts
mehr ich habe wirklich das Gefühl was
soll ich denn jetzt hier sagen was soll
ich denn sagen klingt bescheuert aber
war so war sehr lecker wir hatten
Meeresfrüchte wir hatten so ein
champagnerschaum und Plankton war glaube
ich auch noch mit drin wir waren auf
jeden Fall bereit für alles was noch
kommen sollte und dann ging es in den
nächsten Raum dort ging es um Geschmack
Geschmacksrichtung aber es durfte leider
nicht gefilmt werden deshalb ganz kurz
wir haben wirklich wieder mit einer
tollen Show süß salzig bitte
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtung
kennengelernt und eine standen noch aus
umami vielleicht kennt ihr das dieser
fleischige volle Geschmack den sollten
wir im gleichnamigen nächsten Raum
erleben und schon beim rheinfahren haben
wir gesehen das ist ganz klar
japanisches Stil Holzvertäfelung an den
Wänden werden diese typische Bar die man
aus traditionellen Sushi Restaurants
kennt und ein riesiger Gong gegenüber
der Bar der wurde erstmal geschlagen und
wir wussten okay jetzt geht's los
[Musik]
manch einer ist einfach nur überwältigt
von dem was hier passiert Larry wollte
schon immer einen Gong hören guckt euch
das an umami das ist der Raum den wir
uns gerade befinden die Speise mir mit
Grapefruit Nigiri mit gerösteter Paprika
dem sum schaut euch das alleine an also
ich dachte erst das sei sowas wie so
eine Replik von Sushi weil es einfach so
so real aussah aber wir haben sehr sehr
edle Stäbchen vor uns liegen in goldenen
Löffel und das ist eines der
Hauptgerichte im heutigen Menü ich
glaube wirklich dass das geschmacklich
sehr interessant wird ich würde sagen
wir probieren zu allererst einmal dieser
Chemie mit dem Grapefruit ich nehme hier
ein bisschen Sashimi das einmal in den
Sud und wir probieren
man merkt euch das sind Zutaten höchster
Güte wir nehmen uns hier mal ein
bisschen was von dem Sashimi ihr kennt
das mittlerweile vielleicht von den
anderen Sterne restaurant-videos ich sag
schon einen anderen das Restaurant hier
hat gar keine Sterne aber es fühlt sich
so an man jettet durch Konsistenzen
Geschmäcker Kontraste so auch hier also
Sashimi mit Grapefruit unglaublich
lecker frisch Misosuppe umami ist das
richtige Stichwort sehr herzhaft sehr
intensiv für die Siri mit gerösteter
Paprika
fünf Fleisch rein Gang auch als
Fleischesser absolut vollmundig und
jetzt haben wir noch eine Sache übrig
den dem sum Mitja Soße bin ich mir jetzt
einmal greifen werde vielleicht hätte
ich das mit Stäbchen machen soll und wir
probieren
alter Schwede ich weiß nicht ob ich noch
nie dem Song gegessen habe oder ob ich
noch nie so gute dem Song gegessen habe
absolute Kochkunst Eric guckt mich an
schüttet den Kopf ungläubig ich glaube
wir sind einer Meinung wenn du mir
zustimmst dann leg mal mit der Kamera
und in jedem Moment wo die Kamera mal
nicht lief oder wir einfach nur auf
unseren Stühlen nebeneinander in den
nächsten Raum gefahren wurden haben wir
uns immer vollkommen entgeistert
angeschaut weil es wirklich bin krank
ist Erlebnis war unvergleichlich ist
wirklich das einzige Wort was es trifft
weil ich kann es ja nicht vergleichen
deshalb kann ich es auch schlecht in
Worte fassen aber es war verrückt fünf
Tage später haben wir jetzt wenn ich
diese Moderation aufnehme und ich muss
sagen vor allem das Erlebnis ist mir im
Kopf geblieben das Essen war super auch
so dass es perfekt zum Konzept passt
aber so dieses ganze Spektakel drumherum
das Fahren die Räume die Technik die
Show die Geschichte die auch erzählt
wurde das war wirklich krass und zu dem
Zeitpunkt nach dem umamiraum waren wir
so kurz vorm Höhepunkt weil was dann
abging war krass leider durfte nicht
gefilmt werden ich sage so viel wir
haben die Erde verlassen macht damit was
ihr wollt ihr habt ja drei der Räume
gesehen quasi die Lobby am Anfang den
Ocean Raum und den umamiraum und ihr
könnt euch sicher sein keiner der
anderen Räume hatte weniger zu bieten
das war krass ehrlich ich denke gerade
daran dass das Dessert vom von der Decke
Gefahren ja Leute wir wurden
freundlicherweise sogar eingeladen und
die haben gesagt bitte erzählt nicht zu
viel das mache ich nicht aber ich sag so
viel es ist auf jeden Fall erlebenswert
es war verrückt mit einem Preis von 195
Euro pro Person muss man sagen dass es
keine günstige Erfahrung es ist ein
bisschen so als würde man eine Box
nehmen da wirft man Kino rein ein
Gourmet Restaurant ein Theater ein
Freizeitpark ein Live Auftritt dann
schüttelt man das alles durch und was
rauskommt ist das Restaurant also es ist
viel mehr als nur ein Erlebnis das muss
man wirklich sagen da kann man lange von
Herrn das haben wir getan das waren
tolles Erlebnis und wir dachten auch
alle direkt danach ey wir müssen dem das
zeigen wir müssen dem das zeigen wir
müssen das unseren Eltern schenken weil
es wirklich so cool war Erfahrung zehn
von zehn Essen für Gourmet Standard auf
jeden Fall nicht trotzdem top aber wer
einfach nur essen will ist dort auf
jeden Fall sowieso falsch boah also ich
hoffe dass ihr ein bisschen
an dieser Erfahrung teilhaben konntet
wir haben uns Mühe gegeben dass so gut
wie es geht aufzunehmen es war nicht
ganz leicht aber eine Frage bleibt ist
das das Restaurant der Zukunft schreibt
in die Kommentare würdet ihr das Geld
dafür ausgeben sagt das ist zu teuer hat
euch Lust gemacht ich will gerne wieder
hin hier ist noch ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video darunter kannst du
den Kanal abonnieren bis dahin ciao